merci merci madame la présidente je vais
essayer d'optimiser ses deux minutes
monsieur michel edouard leclerc j'aurais
pu dire de vous que vous êtes un très
bon communicant e vous savez actionner
les coudes comme comme personne et en
particulier la baguette à 29 centimes
que vous vous présentez comme le
chevalier blanc du consommateur tout en
faisant savamment oublier que vous vous
enrichissez puisque dernièrement et
c'était un article qui viennent paraître
vous vous êtes enrichi sur 2021 le prêt
de 75 millions d'euros augmentant votre
rémunération de plus de 40 millions
d'euros par rapport à 2020 je reprends
juste s'il ya lille 2 minutes de fermer
cet article il n'en reste il n'en reste
pas moins vrai il n'en reste pas moins
vrai ce monsieur leclerc que vous avez
quand même une capacité particulière à
contourner les lois vous le faites à
travers votre centrale européenne
leclerc qui refuse de se référer au
droit français et continue de demander
de la déflation sur les matières
agricoles même si parfois vous accepté
de le faire donc cette prise en compte
de la loi et galim concernant les
matières agricoles vous faites
exactement ce qu'il faut pour compenser
toute augmentation que vous payez par
une diminution que vous appliquez sur
les différents produits de consommation
courante non alimentaires vous appris
vous appliquez un véritable jeu de dupes
sur les pénalités puisque ces pénalités
aujourd'hui sont encadrées par la loi et
galim 2 il semblerait comme en bon
communiquant que vous ayez été le
meilleur pendant la crise c'est à dire
celui qui demande le moins de pénalités
mais comme le naturel comme chassez le
naturel il revient au galop vous vous
êtes extrêmement bien appliqué à
appliquer la totalité des pénalités
après la crise de façon à regagner tout
ce que vous aviez perdu au départ
continué de plus belle en modifiant en
modifiant les pénalités par un terme
nouveau qui s'appelle pour vous
indemnités logistique vous continuez de
pratiquer des déductions d'office sur
les factures de façon totalement
arbitraire la question vous pénalisez
vous appliquez vous appliquer des
pénalités sur les commandes non il faut
l'entendre ça vous appliquer des
pénalités sur les commandes portant sur
des produits annoncés en rupture par vos
fournisseurs alors monsieur leclerc ma
question est simple
le respect de la loi et il dans votre
cahier des charges
[Musique]